if you had to boil it down to one word
what's your word for season 10 of
housewives ooh
secrets for a moment there we were like
who's leaking all this stuff below
Garcelle how are you doing in this very
strange time uh I am hanging in the air
by a thread as I tell you where I'm okay
in your cup I mean there are days that
are I'm like this is good you know I'm
hanging out I don't have any of you know
real big responsibilities and then there
are other days I wake up and I'm like I
miss doing things you know and seeing me
volun right going out in the hole but
waiting out in the world I just went to
the market this morning and I was
dressed like a ninja and in the middle
of all this craziness you're gonna make
your debut as a real housewife talk
about crazy myself into it it was really
I mean we shot the season already
obviously but it was really fun and
different and you know I've never
written really around a group of women
that just loved dramas and I'm
interesting to see how I am portrayed
like that or what the women say but I'm
my back in the confessional that's what
I'm exactly the thing that I got the
thing because right now everybody's so
nice
[Music]
[Applause]
well I got involved is you know you have
to be friends of one of the house wives
and I'm friends with not only Denise
Richards we've been friends for over 20
years but also to Lisa Rinna who
everybody knows Rinna right so Denise
invited me to come to New York and come
to meet the girls and so we go to New
York and it was just really there like
rock stars you know what I mean like
coming out of that hotel and people are
like taking pictures and you know
calling out for them and and that was
really interesting to see that side of
it and then getting to know them little
by little and some might got along with
right away so I'm not so much I want to
say thank you to my new best friends
some of them not so much
I mean Rinna because I've known her I
feel like she's a little bit different
on the show so that that will be
developed as it goes on
I'm Erika I loved right away because
I've been a fan of hers I love I feel
like her and I we have similar
personalities in terms of what we say
how we see it and we keep it moving
right and I just love her and I think
she's just a rock star that I'm getting
to know she's cookie and fun but since
the show I've gotten to know her a lot
better we have a lot of similarities her
being a you know single mom and
navigating you know through those waters
who else let's say that all right so
then the only two people you didn't hit
on would be Teddy Oh Teddy's pregnant
you can't you can't go after a regular
but I think Teddy's sweet and then
there's Therese what did you hear a
during this fire Doreen I love but also
Dury can push my buttons really quickly
which I was shocked to see
because I thought I always had it you
know under control but sure we can say
something and it totally gets me the
wrong way and I don't know what it is
about her about or if it's because the
accents and the way she's saying it just
something doesn't look right something
but yeah I don't know what it is just
yet we're figuring it out
were you a fan of the show before did
you watch it I didn't I yeah I was a fan
of the show I was a fan of that one and
also Atlanta cuz I have friends on
Atlanta so I just never thought I'd do
reality I mean when they came to me you
know my managers were like oh we're
gonna pass on that we're just telling
you and I was like you know why not
switch it up I feel like nowadays we're
not boxed into doing one thing you don't
have to be just an actor or writer and
so I thought let's see you what this
world is all about and boy did I get an
introduction did you call any of your
friends in Atlanta head-up time to be
like what is the situation here what do
I need to know what advice - I sure did
I couldn't tell anybody until it was
announced so when it was announced night
I texted it Cynthia and she was like
girl I'm so excited for you you're gonna
be great and then I texted me me and she
was like girl
they're all gonna lie they're gonna see
they're gonna stab you in the back that
sounds I always like it somebody else's
experience is not yours
so wait and see so I was like I took
Mimi with a grain of salt but you know I
don't know what I'm going into at the
now having shot at all who whose advice
was more in line with what you
experienced was it loved it like Cynthia
or beware like Nene actually a little
bit of both what I what I the thing that
was shocking to me that we could be
laughs me and the women could be
laughing and having a good time and then
the next day next thing they're throwing
you under the bus so that took a lot of
getting used to it's like hey you were
just leaning on me cracking up right
then you're like Oh remember you said
that about Lisa Rinna I don't like oh
wow okay yes I didn't say that get some
whiplash
exactly exactly right we
obviously read a lot and heard a lot
about what's going to go down this
season allegedly Denise there is a side
of you that is hidden oh she's not who
she pretends to be I don't deserve this
that is a huge thing to be saying what
could be that bad
what's out there how are the reports
we've seen you know for a moment there
we were like who's leaking all this
stuff because we felt like a lot of it
was sort of factual or actual accurate
but I think you know you have to sort of
go with the journey and see when we know
what we know if we ever actually really
know the truth you know so it's
interesting how it all develops and out
how it all shakes out and I'm team
Denise I mean I still don't know the
truth we still don't know I think if we
will know and think as time goes on and
hopefully Denise will spill the beans
um but I want to believe her I mean I
keep in my friend for over 20 years
but to me taking brandy side over hers
who wouldn't be a friend that's not what
friends are for
I mean she's my friend I'm gonna stick
by her and you know and see how it
shakes out wasn't that girls method
through a lot
she's been through a lot and she always
takes a higher ground I'm always like
Denise become yourself
like no it's okay I'm like girl so she
has been through a lot and so I'm you
know she'll be fine she'll be a good but
they're telling phul they're coming for
her they're coming for but I feel like I
think she took a step back and she's
gonna come right back
she'll have some confessionals to watch
first I think so too and I think the
reunion will be will be filled with a
chock full of drama oh I'm sure I want
to ask about another line you say in the
trailer for me
that is some white people stuff what
were you referring to something that
develops that I find out when we go to
we go to Erica's party they are stralla
G for you first of all you know this
truck ecology party was really fun and
we got to know a lot but I found out
something that Kyle and Teddy did and I
was like white people stop life is an
audition and honey
I am getting that far I mean you are
making history as the first black woman
to join the cast of Beverly Hills what
does it mean to you you know it's so
funny that it's such a big deal and I
think the fact that it's a big deal is
because there hasn't been one so the
fact that it's me I'm thrilled I'm
excited I think you know I bring my
flavor you know to the show and I think
you know it's about time how would you
describe yourself as a housewife like
what are we gonna see from you Oh God
that's a very good way I think I hold my
own I think I hold my own I say it like
I see it and I'm a lot of fun when
you're casting was announced an old
story about an email went around and I
want to know if if that's the energy you
brought to the show yeah yeah because
when I saw that I was like oh this is a
housewife yeah let's just say I am
bringing that yeah absolutely absolutely
you can't you know wrongs wrong and you
know you sometimes you gotta make it
right yeah if it's in the wrong way
sometimes a wrong can correct the wrong
yeah absolutely
overall what surprised you the most
about this experience how the fans react
to the show it's unbelievable I mean I
was an aide to a friend of mine the
other day you know I've been in the
industry over 20 years I've done some
really cool stuff and the announcement
of housewives was the biggest thing ever
I'm just surprised that people are so
interested and invested and they're
picking teams and they're already like
you know
Twitter's like do we stand with Garcelle
and it's you know I think the energy
that the housewives get is really
surprising it's really cool if you had
to boil the whole season down into one
word what's your word for season 10
housewives Oh secrets what are you most
excited for the fans to experience I
think seeing another side of me I think
you know even though I've been an open
book in terms of my life but never
really to this extent where I have
cameras in my house cameras in my car my
kids my ex you know I think people will
get to see me you know besides the
glamor and all that stuff I'm just you
know a regular girl with victory well I
don't think everybody knows that you are
from Haiti and immigration west and
there's that whole story that tell -
yeah absolutely yeah I came at the age
of 7 didn't speak a word of English
learned English you know watching Sesame
Street I'm the I'm living the American
dream honestly is there anything on the
flip side of that that you're dreading
viewer seeing yeah my divorce is not
something that I really am looking
forward to dredging up and I had to have
the conversation with my kids to sort of
tell them that you know things are gonna
come out you know about our divorce and
Mike and I have done such a great job to
get to where we co-parent so beautifully
that I just hope that doesn't change
anything for us because that's really
you know my family's really important to
me whether we're married or not we're
still family yeah excited to see more of
you I hope they send you that first
episode soon because it's chefs kiss
emoji do you really like it I can't wait
yeah it's I'll tell you what it is I had
chills and I wash I had to watch like
three times because I was like I'm I
gotta pay attention to everything
it's happening here oh I love it oh
that's great
I cannot wait I cannot wait to see it I
can't wait
[Music]